hey your baby were you up this far as
you walk away when I'm talking to you
haha fellas get yo [ __ ] together man oh
[Music]
what's going on YouTube last week I put
up a video called ladies get your [ __ ]
together and because of that I got a lot
of responses asked me to do one for the
fellas and you know what ladies you're
right now before we go ahead and get
into this fellas I'm not saying that I
know how to get women 24/7 okay
I'm not Tooting my own horn ooh that
sounds dirty but what I am saying is
that I know a good amount of fellas that
don't know these basic rules and basic
common-sense things so I'm here to help
you out there
let's get it there's only one rule don't
be a scrub and what do I mean by a scrub
it tell me why every single no job
having broke-ass scruffy-looking ugly
ass fool expects to have a fine ass girl
next to him for those of you who this
applies to let me ask you something bull
would you want to be with yourself you
had the audacity that's right the
audacity the judge a girl walking down
the street saying that gonna be hella
ugly [ __ ] you're Quasimodo looking as
we call us somebody else ugly how are
you gonna judge somebody up based on
their looks weak you got a booger
hanging off your helper lip here's
another thing stop asking every dude
when a girl walks by hey Brooke would
you hit there he has a better question
[ __ ] would she let you this may be
something that you may not know in your
mind this is what you look like it was a
baby I do but in reality this is what
you look like
hey we shampoo you want my number kids
another thing when you giggle like a
little bit when they walking by they
know your little jokes in your little
lingo this may come as a shock to you
but women know what TIG ol bitties mean
it's not that hard of a code to figure
out and I really don't understand why
you confuse - why they giving you the
finger all the time check it out check
out those TIG ol bitties uh yeah does
she crack our code if you're looking for
a girl that just wants a fun time that's
easy just give them half a bag of
Skittles and some crack rocks and you're
good to go but if you're looking for
something real like a genuine woman then
you have to step your game up fellas
because it's not that easy to come by
anymore you got the teeth yeah brace
[ __ ]
get a haircut you want your woman to
have a finance body then maybe you
should work out too so simple advice
brush your damn teeth brush your hair
pop the pimple on you make you get a job
[ __ ] notice on my map
I mean what's good Tama yeah yeah who
ejm I know number one rapper North Korea
Kim Jong I notice I'm not laughing
I mean was a lot of responses ask people
who I am